welcome back to the iced coffee hour my
name is matt stoney and uh so far the
podcast has made
one million dollars i didn't no there we
go that's a million dollars i was
thinking i was thinking you know my
little
evil one million dollars that would be
nice yeah it was 183
250 there we go that's a good chunk of
change it is it is it's decent so thank
you so much for coming on of course it's
been long overdue because you also live
in las vegas as do we and uh we finally
were able to get you to come on the
podcast to share everything you're going
to give us all the details all right
about how much you eat
how you're able to grow these videos how
are you able to grow an audience of 10
million uh give us all your personal
finance details how much money you make
your net worth
okay just just go and warm it up a
little bit just slow and slowing into
you know no big deal but uh no i mean
it's been it's been awesome you know
i've i've seen you know um like like you
said you know moved to las vegas and
stuff and i know we've been just you
know hopping skip away and stuff so
been super excited to be part of you
know stuff like this because
the business side of youtube is so
something i'm i feel like i'm warming up
to at this point so it's awesome it'd be
awesome to talk with you guys and just
see what you guys think where are you
from originally
um i lived in i mean i was born in san
francisco okay and i lived in san jose
my entire life for the most part up
until we moved here and it was it was
largely
a space affordability decision like it
wasn't even so much for the taxes which
a lot of people talk about which is
obviously a huge perk but um we got two
dogs and we were paying like 4 500 in
rent for this is a little thousand
square foot apartment
in san jose and then you know
just coming out here we're gonna get a
lawn and it's it just made sense yeah to
provide everyone with a little bit of
background to do some justice okay matt
stoney i've been watching him for i
don't even know maybe like eight years
seven years now it's crazy he basically
gets a lot of food and can eat a lot of
food and and he also eats food fast too
so you're like a competitive eater you
wanna you got like 13 million
subscribers or something ridiculous the
most subscribers i guess has ever had on
our podcast not that we're counting
perry and i think zach king
okay sure exactly there we go yeah okay
so second most second but it's an honor
to have you we're so excited and uh yeah
thank you so much for coming on yeah no
i mean it's it's it's still wild to me
that you know um like we'll talk about
like last year i got out a little bit
more and did more collabs and met more
people and did more you know ventured
out tried to be uh change it up from
just filming in my own kitchen and stuff
but it's still mind-boggling to me that
i went from just eating hot dogs and
burritos and michael phelps 12 000
calorie diet like you know being part of
podcasts and stuff so guys like you you
got it wow now what were you talking
about we were in a podcast with guys
like you
flipped this guy
uh first of all how did you get started
with all of this did you did you know
from a young age that you had like an
ability to eat food or like how does
this come about because surely if you
you know were you 10 years old and
you're just like i have a gift for this
no i mean when i do look back i was kind
of a food guy like i distinctly remember
i was at like one of my friends birthday
parties we're at raging waters and they
got two pizzas and there's like 10
people and each pizza had like
six slices or eight slices i'm like not
everybody's getting two slices and so i
took my pizza and i eat it fast so i can
get a second slice so i've always been
kind of i always love to eat food and
stuff but um no the the competitive
eating really just it came out of
nowhere for the most part i mean
it's all started
well it all started there's like a five
pound burrito in san jose it was
featured on man versus food and i just
like i saw joey chest and that eat it
and i was like i gotta try that i failed
a couple times until i finally did it
but it really kicked off when i did a
lobster roll eating competition it was
just a block away from where my
grandparents were living
there's free lobster rolls ten minutes
who can eat the most lobsters get a
thousand dollars in cash and i was
working the arcade that year i was
getting like seven dollars an hour i
made like
like 600 bucks for the whole summer or
something and at the end of the summer a
bunch of lobster rolls and made a
thousand dollars and i was like oh my
god i'm doing the wrong thing i got to
start like
eating food so um
yeah no that's really the start of it
and then how old are you then 21. okay
the the yeah did you go to college
before then 18 18 18 yeah did you go to
college
no i mean i was that was the summer
before i started going to college okay
so um i started i started i did about
two and a half years of college before
the youtube stuff really started to make
sense to you know change tink paths and
stuff but um
you know i did a couple years of like
also in like math and sciences so i kind
of worked with my competitive eden took
nutrition courses anatomy biology and
just coming up with weird hypothesis of
like how can i figure out how to eat 50
hot dogs and stuff and how can i not be
dead the next day and stuff so um when
you ate the lobster rolls something
clicked for you're like this is this is
it how did you learn how to do that like
did you train for that for the first
thing you ever did
yes
yeah yeah well so i've always been like
i mean everybody says i'm a competitive
person and stuff but like i i did a lot
of tennis and like stuff in high school
and stuff so i kind of had this like
mentality i needed to prepare for things
so i ate like a bunch of broccoli and
like like like like a
steamed zucchinis and stuff just to like
expand my stomach cabbage and all that
to prepare for it and i think the big
thing too was
a lot of retired competitive eaters they
kind of scour the country for these
amateur events
and they try to just like you know
collect the thousand dollars here and
there
and so a couple retired competitive
readers professionals they were there
and i knew like i i couldn't just phone
this in
so um and that was part of the also ploy
of like hey i got something going on
here because i beat the dude by half a
lobster roll and the adrenaline and
everything of being on stage i was like
oh this is so funny that's crazy to me
that there are professionals out there
who go to those events just to get rid
of the cash
okay that's crooked
i know they do them you do you type of
thing but it reminds me when i was when
i was a real estate agent there were
people out there who only went to the
open houses for the free food
and you would see the same people at
this like every single week you knew you
advertised food they would show up it
reminds me of wait these guys are
criticizing them but like two podcasts
ago you're the one who said you used to
do that
well listen because they're going to
come to mind
okay
okay somebody else is to do that
it's like it's like a taste your own
medicine type of thing yeah so they
won't
but that's interesting um so yeah so you
didn't like you've repaired a little bit
but you wouldn't say you knew what you
were doing when you prepared
oh yeah i mean
it's tough it's all relative i mean my
training regimen and what i would do
nowadays to prepare for a contest is
totally different from what i did back
in the days but i also wouldn't
recommend any if you're trying to get
into competitive eating or you're
preparing for a challenge i wouldn't
recommend doing what i do currently
because like this is years of not only
just like figuring out my own body but
just figuring out the body and the body
adapting to consuming so much sodium at
one time and all that yeah i wonder how
to prepare is that what you're doing
well
one other quick question how much do you
think in like if you're a good
competitive eater how much of that is
something that you're born with versus
how much you train for because you i
mean you make it seem like you didn't
train that much from your words right
and you beat these guys who are like
career competitive eaters
i mean i trained a lot i mean i think
i've compared a couple people in the
circuit um i've always been kind of i
felt like i've had to work for like
i'm almost one of the shorter guys on
the circuit a lot of the guys like six
three six four two guys so they got a
bigger torso bigger rib cage and
everything um but um no i had to work
really hard to get to where you know to
like winning contests and stuff
i don't know
what compelled me to push as hard as i
did for that first contest or maybe they
were sleeping on me or something but um
i mean it'd be ignorant for me i get the
this question pretty commonly and i'd
it'd be ignorant of me to say i wasn't
born with some sort of like
elastic stomach or a strong esophagus or
a you know big jaw muscles or something
but um you know especially since
competitive eating is pretty still in
its infancy as far as like you know big
sports that like you don't have people
on payroll just analyzing the sport and
watching what we do it's it's still
pretty homegrown for the most part so i
couldn't quantify it but
sir how do you prepare
like what what did you start out with
what did i start out with um
well i started off by doing challenges
like i mean have you seen man versus
food yeah yeah adam richmond all that um
so i started just kind of going around
the country just trying restaurant
challenges collecting t-shirts free
meals that sort of thing so it was there
was really no focus challenges like this
week i'm traveling and eat a burger next
week i'm going to eat a bunch of like a
12 egg omelet or something
um it wasn't until i started doing
competitive contests that i
really started honing in on specific
foods
and um
it's really as simple as that for the
most part it's like my first
professional contest was deep-fried
asparagus
so i just deep fried a bunch of
asparagus and i started eating it
because um especially you know when
you're training for these things a lot
of it's mental like it's it's it's a
really repetitive thing for the most
part it's like it's
like sprinting on like a path versus
like
i don't know like i compared to power
lifting a lot like there's something
like there's nuances to different
lifting methods but
you just got to grow your muscles for
the most part and what about like your
size because you're not like a
particularly large like a huge person i
would figure that the people doing these
like competitive eating things would be
like you know like nba player type of
physiques you know because then they
could just fit more food right i mean
some of them are big i mean there's a
guy named gideon oggy he's he's
he's killing it recently and he's like
six
nine or something he's a humongous dude
joey chestnut i think is 6'2 or
something oh he is yeah there's a i mean
he i mean he's you know he's a lot of
the guys are pretty big if you look at
the nathan's i'm pretty sure compared to
a lot of them you got to convince
yourself you got to find ways to keep
pushing and stuff and i just you know
kobayashi back in the day he was a small
dude too yeah he was like my statue
roughly even potentially smaller so i
was like if he could do it i can do it
but first we want to thank our sponsor
ftx jack graham just paid me looks like
somebody's getting new tv alex you
should really do something smarter with
that money like what like investing it
with ftx ftx is the best crypto exchange
trusted by over six million people to
buy sell and keep track of all of their
favorite cryptocurrencies just download
the ftx app and you can start buying and
selling crypto in minutes the ftx app
gives you important news updates and
news feeds directly from top crypto
projects and for every time you make a
trade over ten dollars you can earn free
crypto with fdx you can also set up
recurring buys which allow you to invest
money directly from your bank account
automatically every single month so now
you can constantly be investing in
crypto without even having to think
about it and unlike other exchanges that
charge you a fee anytime you make a
transaction or withdraw money the ftx
app has no fees whatsoever and you can
now use the ftx app to buy your favorite
nfts with no gas fees supporting both
the ethereum and solana blockchains ftx
also offers a crypto friendly debit card
allowing you to spend crypto at millions
of different merchants worldwide so
start trading crypto and nfts today with
no fees whatsoever with the link down
below in the description on ftx again
guys the link is down below in the
description to download ftx to get
started trading crypto and nfts with no
fees thank you so much ftx and back to
the podcast growing up i remember
hearing about kobayashi like a lot yeah
and it was always cool to see him like
in the newspaper or whatever like
watching him on tv but then you did i
mean the big eating contest is nathan's
yep right like that's that's the main
one where you stuff down like absurd
amounts of hot dogs and you like dip the
buns in the water and it looks crazy and
you did nathan's what was this like
like two years ago or you've done it
multiple times yeah but you won it
yeah no that was i mean i've done
nathan's i think nine times
unfortunately i couldn't make it 10
because kovid kind of right made that it
just cut it off kind of but um
yeah i've done nathan's between 2011 and
i guess 19. um so
i've been a regular there but um yeah
it's 2015 where i top joey chestnut that
was a pretty big moment because he had
he hadn't still does to just they
dominate that contest for the most part
so um because i think he beat kobayashi
for the first time in 2007
and that's the only year he's lost since
it's a pretty incredible uh winning
streak so that was that was that was a
huge i still remember
it was like an auto battery experience
like you just you didn't expect it to
happen yeah yeah and it just like it
happened i remember hearing about that
when it happened and i was like heck
yeah i was so stoked because i knew joey
chestnut he was like the reigning
champion and i you know watched your
video so i was a fan and you did it and
you won and i was just like so stoked
for you it's crazy because you're not
like good at competitive eating you're
like you're fantastic you're dominant it
it's
not understood how you're actually like
i don't know i feel like people look
past it you're actually very dominant in
the sport
thank you yeah
thank you i mean that that means a lot
because i mean
yeah i mean i i put a lot of work into
it and you know it paid off and i i
think um
to to your point you know you ask her
about like natural talent and stuff i
think a lot of times um
the hard work and like the the regimen
that i had leading up to events is what
helped me be consistent throughout the
year like i think joey like he's really
dominant in nathan but he tends to beat
spotty he gives up a contest here and
there and stuff just because he doesn't
like prepare as much for it or something
whereas i always prepared like i figured
out a new technique or something that
would something that give me the edge
yeah in each event and stuff and i think
that helped i think with my overall
track record i'm curious with these guys
who compete did they do this full time
or do they got a job and this is like a
weekend thing or they'll train and
compete and they'll do this on the side
most people
it's a side time thing which
which is a love and hate relationship
because i'd love to see the sport grow
i'd love to see more people be able to
you know become more lucrative and
people can make a career and focus and
and that's what that was the turning
point for me is i knew if i had if i was
going to top joey if i was going to win
nathan's the big contest i'd have to
commit full-time
but most people you know you can't
there's not a ton of money in the sport
still
and a lot of people have lives and
families which like i said is
bittersweet for me because it also makes
it fun because a lot of people just do
it because they love doing it and stuff
so it's a great group of people to hang
out with and interact with but i'd say
you know myself joey mickey pseudo
women's female champ
she couldn't compete last year so former
female champion you know she'll be back
or kobayashi um
yeah they're not too many people that do
it full full time yeah if anything if
anything there's more competitive eater
youtubers
that do it full time which is
not to be snobby or anything it's kind
of weird because competitive it's
youtube it's not you you're doing it
yourself
that's the most that's the phrase that
sticks so got it yeah so to give people
an idea for nathan's how long do you
have to eat hot dogs and how many hot
dogs did you eat in your most successful
year you have 10 minutes 10 minutes the
contest used to be eight but then when
the numbers got high or no
it used to be 12 and then they brought
it back because they caught too many hot
dogs yeah yeah right but um they haven't
changed it since even though they've
gone up
um now i did 62 the year i won oh my god
what is that how many
what's the average per hot dog
62 that's one every minute 10 seconds i
mean that the
yeah yeah roughly i mean it's much
faster like
the the math behind it traditionally is
by three minutes you have to be halfway
done
so by three minutes you if you hit 31
you're on pace for 62. because you slow
down it gets miserable your job gets
tired to get full it's not only that oh
so you get full that is a like a
definitely a component of
competitiveness
how did you not throw up i would i would
get to the point where does that
disqualify you if you throw up yeah yeah
yeah if if you ever they call it a
reversal fortune on the on the stage and
um that's
it's one of those things where i mean i
guess
and this is where competitive reading is
not as pretty you know behind the scenes
is like i push my limits harder behind
like in training and stuff so when i go
on stage i'm 100 ready for it so i do
like 12 15 minute practice runs just to
push my limits so that when i go on
stage i'm not doing something i've never
done before i'm not in
waters you know so and how many hot dogs
would you say into the 62 would you say
until you like start feeling full
i mean god that was so long ago um
nathan's is a weird one because
everybody prepares for it so much it
becomes almost like riding a bike by the
time you're up on stage you're just kind
of an autopilot
um but i distinctly remember it was
a contest i prepared for but not too
much it was a brand new contest they
only didn't want your hard-boiled eggs
and i think i ate 121 in eight minutes
like that it was but it was so bad like
that was
i mean i've done some impressive stuff
in my days but i just remember
i was getting full and i looked back i
was like okay i'm getting full where are
we so far in the car i look back it's
like
two and a half minutes into the car
i was like this is gonna be this is
gonna be like a
long night out here so
it changes you know i think if you're
more prepared for something you just you
mentally know what to expect you lost
that one
yeah unfortunately second place to joey
wow
when you eat hard-boiled eggs do you
chew them i would assume i chewed them
yeah i think okay
i forget what i was doing it was pretty
fresh i think because they're kind of
slimy on the outside so i feel like you
could just swallow it because if you
chew it it's dry on the inside
but if you chew it i i would imagine
it's more compact than just swallowing
them whole it's it's always it's always
between what you guys are saying because
you got it you can't chew too much but
if you don't chew too much it doesn't
sit well in your stomach so
i think kobayashi has the guinness
record for eggs and i think he just
swallowed them in that just like a video
of him
um and i think during the contest you
could tell joey was chewing a lot less
than i was huh so swallowing him like
retrospectively yeah having those eggs
they wouldn't sit properly if they were
whole so yeah a little bit of chewing
i'm curious how many people after they
finish
you know
have a reversal you have to use the
restroom right yeah yeah you got a
reversal in the toilet bathroom because
i don't know if
i would be able to eat that much and
then just be like all right well yeah
you but you haven't trained that's true
yeah yeah that's true yeah i mean i
can't speak for other people i mean like
generally after the contest i'm pretty
wiped out i'm just in my own i'm just
like depressed deep breath type of thing
so
i mean i know what happens you know like
you can
we do extreme stuff you know and we push
our bodies to our limits and some days
like maybe it's really hot out maybe the
foods like like sweet stuff is pretty
rough sometimes just like sweet contest
so much sugar but um for the most part i
mean like i said you know i push my
limits in practice so that nothing bad
happens on stage so generally speaking
after you catch a breather and that
that's another
i know
it's not the direction this podcast i
feel like it's like talking about the
intricacies it's like it's really hard
to keep like oxygen flowing through your
system because you're using the same
pipe
so like the breathing and stuff is
something that can choke you up and like
sometimes after an event like all you
need to do is just breathe a little bit
yeah
you'll feel good you'll feel a lot
better yeah is it ever dangerous to like
not obviously you could choke and stuff
like that but to eat so much food and to
like stretch out your stomach oh of
course i mean it's
doing anything in excess in extreme like
tennis people get tennis elbow like yeah
tennis players get tennis elbow um you
know like mma fighters that's obvious
you know yeah
football players you know with yeah
customs and stuff um
doing anything in an extreme environment
like this isn't inherently healthy um
but the important part and what i credit
to you know part of my success at least
is just knowing where my limits is and i
don't
i don't cross that line on a frequent
basis like i know where it is i play
with the edge and i just
but then recovery is also the other big
part of it just doing proper recovery
and giving your time enough your body
enough time to rest
in in my case diet exercise yeah and all
that stuff so
it's not it's not healthy i wouldn't
like if somebody's saying like it's what
you do healthy of course not like we're
eating way an excessive amount of food
but um
you know there's plenty of things that
people that aren't healthy it's all
about moderation right and you're pretty
fit too so i'm assuming you probably
have like a pretty gnarly like workout
routine and stuff uh i don't feel too
fit i feel like i've been slacking off a
lot um because
i found that diet is more
helpful long term because
the taxation on the body yeah it's like
it's impossible to go in the treadmill
and see 10 000 calories yeah yeah the
treadmill so um so i found diets like
the best way to handle
what competitive eaters do because you
just you can't physically work off that
much with i mean i used to do it a lot
more but then i would just feel like
garbage in the off season and just be
like fatigue and just like not you know
sleeping right and stuff so
as i recently you focus on diet take a
couple extra days off you can eat it and
just listen to your body but first i
want to thank our sponsor grammarly it's
crazy to think that it's already the
third month of 2022 yet i feel like i've
already sent out six months worth of
emails where is the time going and how
do i get it back well jack if you want
to save time writing emails just install
grammarly sorry guys alex isn't here for
this i just have to improvise grammarly
is an all-in-one writing tool that helps
you communicate clearly and effectively
even when you're short on time i mean
just ask graham ever since i installed
grammarly on his computer he's been able
to write scripts and send emails in just
a fraction of the time grammarly is just
like having a professional writer go
through all of your work 24 7. their
free version is also amazing since it
protects you from basic spelling grammar
phrasing and punctuation but the real
magic happens when you upgrade to
grammarly premium grammarly premium
offers clarity suggestions and even full
sentence rewrites to help you clearly
convey your message and avoid
miscommunication asking out your next
tinder date via email while grammarly's
built-in tone detector can help you
sound as confident professional or as
formal as you need they also offer vocab
suggestions to help replace overused
words phrases and also words you really
do need grammarly man get through those
emails and your work quicker by keeping
it concise confident and effective with
grammarly so check out grammarly.com
iced coffee and sign up for a free
account and when you're ready to upgrade
to the premium account you can get
twenty percent off just for being a
listener once again that's twenty
percent off grammarly premium at
g-r-a-m-m-a-r-l-y
dot com slash iced coffee thank you so
much grammarly for sponsoring this
episode and back to the podcast when did
youtube come in
it came out you start doing that yeah i
know i mean it
it's always weird to
describe it because i feel like
especially nowadays a lot of youtubers
they're like
they've been wanting to become a
youtuber and this thing like i'm going
to become a youtuber it was it was never
so cut and dry for me like
i uploaded my first the
lobster roll contest and i uploaded the
challenges i did because i saw man
versus food now it's like i saw what he
was doing there i enjoyed the content
and um there was a couple people like
epic meal time back in the day they were
doing their thing love their love their
content so i always i felt very
it didn't take long for me to fall in
love with the process the creative
process of taking
this event that i thought was fun like a
30 minute took me 35 minutes to eat a
burger
it was fun for me i was adrenaline
everything yeah i watched the tape back
it's boring you know i'm just sitting
there smacking for 35 minutes so my
first videos i was putting like my
favorite music just and speeding it up
and through it and uh
yeah i just there's something super
rewarding and super interesting to me to
like make this content
more palpable for i wasn't even thinking
about a broader audience at that point
but it was like even for just for me
just like making it more entertaining to
watch um but not losing any context
either you know not like just doing like
long cuts and stuff just like figuring
out how to right
package it in more condensed form so it
just evolved you know um
i think
i just you know video started taking off
the michael phelps diet challenge that
was my first viral video and i was like
explain that
i know i'm creating it but yeah
absolutely explain the challenge
how you came up with the concept
how you filmed the video how when did it
go viral
how did that change for you i think i
put i forget i think it was 2012 when i
posted it but i mean
michael phelps you know he was yes you
know olympian doing everything crazy he
was you know headlines and everything
and he he posted something about his 12
it's crazy 12 000 which apparently later
he said he's like exaggerating about or
something i don't know but um no i mean
who don't eat that much food you know
right on normal basis i get it but um he
posted it and every like all the news
they're like talking about i was twelve
thousand guys he
the the best olympian the road he's
three pizzas a day and like all this
like like you know the rock did the same
thing he posted these pancakes and
pizzas and
so um being in the competitive eating
space i was like oh dude that sounds
like
i want to do that you know like it
sounds fun you know so um
i just
bought the food a lot of swimming caps
stupid you know and feel like yeah
i was on just you know played the part a
bit and uh yeah that was my that was my
first viral hit um i don't even remember
how i
like interpreted that or like digested
information i was obviously mind-blowing
to get a million views on a video
but um yeah there was never a point in
time really for the most part outside of
when i kind of stopped doing schooling
um where i was like
this is what i what i'm doing it was
always progressive i was always like
just yeah is it fun is it is it
does it pay does it you can pay the
bills type of thing am i enjoying it am
i making progress
and um
yeah i mean it's like i like i started
off at the top saying you know i'm still
learning the business side of youtube
and everything like it's just constantly
evolving so when you're posting youtube
videos did you have a schedule
no
i've always shot and i still shoot for
like one a week and stuff and um
never really had a schedule i felt like
to me the most important part was
conveying to my audience that
there would be more content
and that there was going to be something
that's coming maybe it comes in a week
maybe get two this week maybe you have
to wait a month or something but that
there'd always be something coming to
look forward to and yeah
if you waited longer i'll post a better
video or something like this
you know like and it's not something
this week it'll be better next week yeah
exactly type of thing so you know
there's always been that pressure of you
know if i take a break i kind of gotta
come back banger you know but um
yeah so i've never adhered to a schedule
and i think
it's it's always something i've been
wanting to do just for my own sake you
know just being on a clock you know
human psychology just trying to not be
scattered all the time but um
yeah i think right now i'm trying to
shoot to do like two to three a month
got it but at what point did you realize
youtube was full-time for you or that
you could do it as a career because you
mentioned going to college for two years
yeah did you drop out
um
i guess that's the term you'd use yeah i
just stopped
i was just sitting in class one day and
i was just like
i was like i was i was looking at a
petri dish like mold and i was just like
i was just like
i want to be thinking about my next
challenge and making my next youtube
video and stuff so
um i don't
i don't
vividly remember
when i said like this is
a career sustainable yeah i remember
seeing my first adsense says like ten
dollars today i'm like oh my god i made
a ten dollar bill today i remember that
distinctly
i
i don't yeah i don't really recall i
mean i remember the first
time i i i cracked a hundred
in a year and i was just like damn dude
this is this is something serious
and how long did it take uh of you doing
youtube to crack a hundred thousand
dollars
i want to say 13 14. it's like maybe
four years on youtube to get to that
point and i think that was also combined
with the competitive eating yeah because
i
i
i would say probably until like 1718
i was still
priority competitive eater yeah like
youtube was still just that i mean i
took it seriously but it was still like
right like if it was between making a
youtube video preparing for a contest it
was always preparing for a contest so it
wasn't until like 17 18 when things
started really blowing up the channel
was millions of subscribers where i was
like
you know maybe i'll skip this contest
because i gotta pick and choose my
battles so i can focus on the youtube
side of things yes how do you pick what
you're gonna eat on youtube
that's a tough question um
gut feeling at this point i don't have a
rigid
like um methodology for what i pick i i
try to keep it switched up like
sometimes spicy sometimes large quick
fast
savory fast food homemade cooking
you know just trying to just give
variety and stuff but um
yeah that's all that's that's the that's
the golden question all the time it's
just like what's that next video that
people are going to make people happy or
sometimes just like hey what's that
what's that yeah video that's just like
a yeah the trending stuff too because
you did the mr beast chocolate thing and
i noticed that did particularly well for
you which is smart right yeah that's
what you so that was cool that was the
first time i've ever gotten like product
early to like yeah
we've been trying to work and like
reaching out to like fast food places
like if they got like the travis got me
or something coming up just getting
hands on a little early and stuff it's
tough working with food establishments
with competitiveness do they not take
you seriously because i feel like for it
like if subway came out with a new like
meatball marinara something like that
like them giving it to you
that was massive
massive promotion i mean from my vantage
point it yeah it makes it it's a
no-brainer if if an opportunity like
that ever came up
it's
okay i mean there's a little history to
this so i remember one of my original
viral videos it was back in like 2013 i
ate four chipotle burritos and a diet
coke or something blew up or whatever
it was like no no big deal but it blew
up and i remember seeing like on twitter
chipotle their handle replied to
somebody said hey check out this video
chipotle and they're like we prefer to
see our burritos enjoyed i was like oh
okay did that hurt at all or no
but yeah it was like i got the message
type of thing it was like i knew you
know yeah but you know that some
probably some yeah yeah you know intern
in college just handling their twitter
no but then but then the flip side of
that coin is i think recently i forget
which house it was one of the streamer
houses they had a chipotle eating
contest
i was like okay you know things might be
changing a bit and i think you know that
was when i was fresh too it's 2013. yeah
and um
you know i think there's a hesitancy
because even i battle with it it's like
how do i make what i'm about to do
appealing and not gross like i from the
zombie video i promoted a video game
recently as a zombie game it was like
they wanted me to eat like ribs and like
like how do i make this i don't like
hate this video and just feel grossed
out by it that's hilarious i was like
okay i'm gonna
i'm just gonna show all the beautiful
barbecue and stuff and i'll just get cut
through the eating you know and stuff so
it's it's a trick and it's been it's
been a challenge like we're talking
about like the asmr like snacking our
lips like yeah i leave some in there so
they know what's going on but i don't go
full blown asmr you know yeah so it's a
trick and you know i feel like you know
as with i've seen youtube over the years
it's like you know just um traditional
companies and media just warming up to
the idea of the value so they've not
reached out to you as like the go-to's
they do influence their marketing
chipotle does like like david dobrik you
know he has the chipotle deal
yeah but i feel like this is just as
good if not like
i wish i had a gold card or whatever
they call it yeah it'd be pretty cool
you know um i'm not out there looking
for that like yeah at the end of the day
you know it's it's a trade-off at the
end of the day you know and you know
if it happens it happens like i just i'm
gonna roll with the punches you know it
would be a match made in heaven
houston houston yeah oh you know houston
he's a youtuber here in vegas yeah okay
he has like he rents out cars and stuff
and tells crazy stories about people who
like drive his car yeah he had one of
the most successful podcasts on here
blown away
it was so good but yeah he uh he pulled
up an alexis lfa okay has the wildest
stories he has a hundred lamborghinis
yeah okay and he has a chain of
restaurants called houston's chicken
here in las vegas really okay but he has
what is it the
black card yeah but no well he is the
black card so basically you could go in
the houston's restaurant just order
whatever you want for free but he has
the hottest uh chicken or the hottest
food on record what what is it like two
million scoville universities i don't
know what it is something really crazy
that you have to sign a waiver to get
this thing
you could just go to the franchise and
just yeah yeah he rejected people like
when they try to order it too okay yeah
yeah like children yeah like a child
like a mom wanted a child to get it or
whatever yeah yeah yeah
but if you did that
we could put you in touch with you i had
no idea
short list now i mean that's that's
right down my i mean yeah spice i have a
weird
relationship with spice because when i
started i was like i know spice i gotta
take care of my stomach and stuff
but damn those videos do good yeah the
spicy challenge videos they do so good
if you ate the hottest chicken sandwich
you should like
do it graham don't put them in danger
man okay come on but like show an
average person show jack eating one of
them
and then show you eating like 10. no but
okay but that's the misconception i can
eat a lot of food but i still have
human tissue yeah i'm still i'm still
made of the same
carbons and whatever you know yeah it
burns the same for me for the most part
i mean i i think psychology i can deal
with
the discomfort and pain yeah food-wise
and stuff but it burns all the same for
me on those special spices yeah there's
some people out there that the spice the
spice world is a whole different like
spice heads and stuff but um
i'm cut from the same cloth as far as
that goes just saying i think that would
be a it would be a banger video we could
put you in contact with them oh yeah
that'd be great that'd be awesome yeah
is it actually black yeah yeah it looks
like an american express card it's
custom made yeah metal yeah uh but it
says uh what is it houston's on the top
yeah oh no the chicken oh the chicken i
don't know if the chicken oh i thought i
said that was like the black chicken or
something
cause sometimes the spicy stuff
dark red i've seen a picture of it i
mean just imagine like this deep like
tissue red looking we gotta eat that
graham we gotta try it come on just one
bite can we get some in like 30 minutes
i mean
you should can we get houston to swing
by with the hottest chicken
um
would are you serious i'll call him
right now are you guys serious
absolutely
i do this for a living
i also have another surprise we'll get
into that yeah hold on just so you guys
know i can barely eat hot cheetos
without crying really brother wow you
picked up hey uh do you mind you're on
the podcast right now is that okay
oh let's do it okay hey so i'm with matt
stoney right now are you familiar with
who he is
no okay
he's on he's on youtube he's got 10
million subscribers and he just
15 terrible 15 million subscribers
yeah
how much youtube i've been watching
lately i know uh so he does food
challenges and we said this would be the
the best collaboration is to
uh put together
houston's chicken and matt stoney and we
were talking about the the hottest
chicken sandwich
what do you think the chances are that
you'd be able to get someone to bring
down the hottest chicken sandwich in the
next like 35 minutes
so he could we could all try it on the
podcast is is that at all possible
75 minutes is a little tight yeah
because it's fresh made to order
there we go it's going to take us about
12 minutes to make it and about 25
minutes to drive it to you but it's
possible
um yeah i mean we'll be here for a while
that's a good end of the podcast you
know just sweating or yeah we could we
could
do it right now right now yeah like 40
minutes
i would have absolutely no problem
getting this to you i also would like to
invite matt we have a challenge that
we're about to launch
like crazy you're calling me
if you can eat ten
houston we have a problem tenders that's
what we just said someone listen it's
five thousand dollars if you could eat
ten tenders
yes
dude
yes
but maybe we just save it for that and
then we do like a collab if you want or
i don't know whatever but he could be
the first person to do that food
challenge
yeah he'll win you may as well pay him
now yeah
seriously i don't know i have never been
able to even smell that tender let alone
so i'm not
two million squabble units perch
which is pretty wicked
[Laughter]
i'm a professional right he's doing my
job yeah i can't back down
he might be weird
i just gotta put the blindfold down we
still should eat the the sandwich though
because that's not gonna be as hot yeah
with the lettuce yeah if we could do the
sandwich though if if you could have
someone bring it by yeah this is what
i'm gonna do i'm gonna send you
sandwiches that are not the spiciest i'm
going to send you liftoff which is a
lower level before the spiciest and
that's going to get your appetite wet
that's 50 percent of houston we have a
problem it's one million scoville units
okay that is absolutely out of this
world insanely spicy yeah okay and you
can expect
double
from the tender okay what do you think
about that i might talk to you is that
hot enough or is that or or should we go
we gotta go to hottest
yeah we can get the hottest even if it's
just one chicken tender yeah
okay there we go houston thank you thank
you listen i'll send you one tender yeah
and if matt can handle the challenge
we'll uh
we'll we'll go for that wait
houston if you could could you maybe
send like because i think we want to try
it too of course i'm going to send you
extra food thank you i'm going to say
that you can eat one tender on this
podcast
and i invite you for the challenge after
this perfect yeah and i'm gonna i'm
gonna put this under your black card
gram so don't worry thank you man
houston thank you not sponsored by you
can link down below but go check them
out anyway go check him out
is not sponsoring this video by chance
thank you thank you thank you man i'm
gonna get that there let me get off the
phone let me call my gm and all my habit
market to you
just text me uh text me your address
we'll do all right we'll do it thanks
bye holy wow it just got interesting
yeah it did so we got that we got that
looming on the horizon for the next you
guys gonna stick around okay we need the
retention there we go there we go abd
getting that up yep
holy cow wow okay good on him
wow
the man
i'm working tonight here we go yeah wow
that's nuts
good on houston yeah i didn't know i
didn't expect that oh yeah it's amazing
and you regret on the side of the table
no not at all i'm so excited
i was gonna ask um you know you're
saying that chipotle and big brands
don't you know they're not really as
interested in working with you but for
me what about have small brands like
local places reached out because think
about it as a local business owner to
have matt stoney coming into my
restaurant to do like whatever challenge
early that that's huge uh do smaller
companies reach out too or no i mean i
got a few ways to look at this i mean
short answer is no i haven't had that
opportunity too much i mean i think a
lot of the content that
i've done is predominantly just like in
my own kitchen and stuff and i've done
that for a handful reason to leave the
door open for expansion down the line to
get out and travel for challenges and
stuff
but um
yeah it hasn't that opportunity hasn't
presented itself too too often but what
i do know is at least on the competitive
eden circuit a lot of contests
smaller contests per you know but a lot
of the contests are actually like local
um talent eateries and stuff that are
like showcasing their their local dish
and stuff like the first contest i ever
won was the slug burger wood eden
championship it was in corinth
mississippi they have this thing called
a slug burger because it cost a slug
back in the day a nickel or something
this is the fried pork patty with
mustard onions and pickles you know
what's not to like about it and um so a
lot a lot of small you know small towns
small businesses and stuff they do
sponsor these events too to kind of get
the name out there it's interesting
because we actually have relations with
jack in the box like
they watch like all of our comments they
comment on us i'll dm them on instagram
they'll give backgrounds yeah it's crazy
follow you on it yeah they follow me
they don't even follow me no we're close
we're japanese yeah they're the best we
love jack in the box i think they i
think they dropped the comment on
something i did recently i think i uh
what was it i mean i i did i did a tick
tock or something or
with the thing and they have the
comments right yeah i mean they're
they're team cool yeah they talk with
influence and stuff like that i'm sure
yeah that's what more brands should be
doing they imagine chipotle's just
browsing youtube commenting
i
someone whose full-time job is just to
watch and comment like they have to get
20 comments out today yeah like we get
all the spam comments
there's no way true
mcdonald's should be doing this stuff
yeah you know all the brands yeah i
think wendy's was like the original yeah
so they had the social media team that
was kind of cool taco bell does it
pretty well too yeah a handful of yeah a
lot of people move that some some are
hit or miss you know but
it's it's smart you know that's that's
that's what you need to do nowadays
right so let's walk through a little bit
of like your your finances throughout
your life because i mean you said when
you first started doing competitive
eating you were working for like seven
dollars an hour and then slowly you know
pretty slowly actually like it took you
four years to to crack a hundred
thousand dollars right between both
youtube and competitive shooting um how
did that progress from then on until
like now um how did it progress it was
mainly just pretty much
more views more views that was pretty
much what it was i mean
like we kind of talked a little bit at
the top you know competitive eating you
know there's not like you know there's
not anything crazy out there contests
usually if you win a contest for most of
them it's like 2500 to first place if
you factor in like the weeks of practice
and all that stuff that you have to go
through
you know kind of you know it's not like
anything crazy and stuff and nathan's
even pays only ten thousand right which
whole other discussion i don't know
fourth of july espn series 10 000 in the
first place it's it's rough but um
but um yeah it was really just more
views on youtube working with
sponsorships that was another big thing
too is finally you know working with
some brands and everything
um but it's been pretty and like you
know like i said you know the business
side of stuff i kind of took it more as
just a personal passion hobby of mine
maybe i missed a few opportunities here
and there but um
yeah i mean it really just comes down to
views and i know you know if just
watching the podcast and your guys's
content and stuff
i can attest the
ad rates and all that stuff competitive
eden it's tough it's not that great it's
tough i mean we've been working on it
and we've been making a lot of progress
over the past couple years um
but you know it's
can you give us a ballpark on like let's
say get a million views sure um my
channel would be anywhere from like 15
grand to probably 30 on the high end 30
would be
high i mean i think
it's tough
i think last time i checked
i was getting like roughly like three
per
three per dollar yeah
something in that ballpark wow it was a
lot worse too i think
we ought to get that number up like 50
in the last year honestly yes yeah
so it's it's
that's crazy it's been tough and i mean
like you know i've talked to a lot of
people who are kind of in the same boat
you know just their content like
especially like i think nowadays like
kids content is really tough yeah and
stuff but um
you know
you know what can i do i'm a competitive
eater yeah food that's the content so
just deal with it who's your who's your
audience
um mainly i mean i think demographic
wise 18 to 24.
um male predominantly yep there we go
from ventura yeah yeah yeah yeah
california is the biggest by far there
we go but um
yeah no i mean that's it's
pretty cut and dry nothing really too
crazy i mean is it us audience space or
is it around the world it's u.s i think
a lot of times canada and the uk creep
in there as top contenders but i think
india's been a huge emerging market a
lot of people from india have been
watching um oddly like philippines and
indonesia
oddly enough are weirdly large markets
and
which is interesting because also like
competitive eating is huge in japan or
they call it they do it's not
competitive eating it's like
food fighters and stuff
but i guess they had their own market
because like i haven't figured out to
get into japanese audience yet so
yeah that's pretty much it just mail
18 to 24. the main main market for the
most part that's interesting i thought
ad rates would be at least higher yeah
it's yeah it's it's it's a struggle i
mean i'm i'm happy with it you know like
i'm i'm not sitting there like cursing
out that youtube algorithm or anything
like like i've made a living i'm sure
i'm happy with what i've done so far of
course i'm always striving to do better
but um you know there's some case
studies like last year i did a chicken
sandwich tearless video and that thing
got like seven like like double what i'd
normally get on ad rates and stuff so
just like figuring out like like fast
food almost as well like i've seen that
it kind of makes sense why don't they
advertise on your videos and stuff i
don't know i don't watch my videos
to get those
but i mean i guess i guess that's
probably something to do with that like
that was the month you were just
refreshing yeah yeah right um
yeah so i mean like i said you know i'm
happy with what i'm getting of course i
know you know just from seeing other
people and that's
it's been a learning process you know i
know you talked with reed and knight
media i joined knight media recently and
they've been kind of showing me the
ropes and like what to expect and like
what to get from sponsors and stuff and
i remember like i forget the year um
just like years ago i was getting
at the time i was like stoked to get
sponsors but retrospectively they were
they were they're pinching pennies on me
i was yeah i was getting just cut at the
knees and stuff and then um my
girlfriend actually who who helps me out
and works with me now um she saw other
people like she watches like makeup
tutorials and where they get good
returns and she's just like what are you
saying you got this much and i was like
that's what i get and um
she's so she helped me out and helped
turn that around a bit but
yeah i mean it's again i can't complain
but always striving to move upwards at
this point um
do you try to ensure that every video is
a sponsor in it
i'm not so picky about that in fact if
anything i try to ensure that not every
video has a sponsor because
you know like i also said you know i
haven't really gotten too many food
sponsors so the tie-ins aren't so
like seamless and perfect all the time a
lot of times it's just like hey check
out
this this company you know check out
this company and you know
um so i i try to make it not feel like
every single time i but it's it's been
good it's been good you know for the
most part i've been
had plenty of sponsors you've been happy
with so tell us about your team is it
just
how did it start obviously just you yep
um
then how did it evolve from there is it
always mostly been you like filming
editing do you have a team do you have
assistance
working on it
i mean i'd imagine it's constantly a
progressive process but um
yeah right now it's just myself my
girlfriend and we just recently got a
videographer to help film stuff
so that's it yeah right now it's
i've had
i'm gonna even go into it but i've had
tough luck with hiring people like no no
let's go into it now it's time to go
into it what's happening i mean it all
started
it all started when i was looking
through contracts and i hired a lawyer
to look at contracts and paid them so
much you know hundreds like a thousand
plus dollars it's like oh it looks good
i was like what about this and he's like
oh yeah that's concerning i was like
what did i just pay you for i was just
it all started there and um i'd imagine
the hiring process is not an easy thing
that's why companies you know they're
not easy to make and stuff but you know
it's
it's just finding that those right group
of people and i've been working with a
lot of editors so it's not just us three
like we've been working with editors and
stuff
and it's
not full-time positions like we're just
testing them out trying to find if it
fits and everything but um
for the most part right now it's
pretty small
a close team for the most part and uh
yeah trying to expand so is it you doing
all the filming editing thumbnails
titles
um
yeah mostly that's really impressive you
don't hear many 10 million plus
subscriber channels doing it all
themselves very few yeah and i mean
part of me is you know a little proud to
say that yeah and naturally but also
part of me is like that's not where i
want to be consistently and i also don't
want to take away you know like hide the
videographer he's been doing a great job
i don't need to worry about getting the
good shots and everything so he's been
helping a ton
and uh you know we've been working with
editors sometimes their thumbnails are
better than the ones that i come up with
sometimes the videos like they come up
some good ideas and it just makes it
that much easier to finish the product
yeah um so it's it's
the goal is to get to the point where i
can you know have less obligations on my
shoulders constantly so we can focus on
more the creative side of things we
tried a creative director last year
didn't work out and um
yeah it's been it's it's been tough
especially when you see a lot of
youtubers nowadays they've got teams of
like people like 20 30 people it's like
oh my god that's that's that's something
else it's impressive right how much
would you say you work right now like
hours on a week
ah i mean
i that's a tough one i mean i'm sure you
can attest to this too like
you don't it's not nine to five it's
hard sometimes it's spending slacking
off and just
you know just chilling out and some days
you're just grinding like non-stop um
let's say
50 60 a week
i've never i've that's not sure yeah
it's the same for us there's no right
nine to five yeah i'm almost thinking
for your content though if it's working
white you don't necessarily need to hire
more people if it's if it's the system's
working i'm always a fan if it's not
broken don't try to fix it that's been
my thought for many years
but
you always got i mean at least and you
know you always got to find ways to just
vertically just keep growing and just
like how do i make my content better
well if i'm constantly glued on a
computer editing all the time or i'm
just like stuck on an edit and i'm just
sitting there for a day just like why
can't i get this intro why can't i
figure this out like that could be used
with me thinking of the next
big crazy food challenge or just like
just training just taking care of i was
under the assumption that you had like a
team around you at all times because uh
we've been trying to schedule with you i
think through alex or was it you jack
yeah yeah i was doing something yeah
yeah for months and and he's like
matt has the schedule available it was
like three months in advance
these this month
uh between these days let us know if
that works and we're like yes that works
well you know as we got close
this schedule moved around and now it
has to be in a few weeks from then at
this day i was like oh god it gave us
the impression or me wow he must be like
really busy uh or like he must have a
big team to because when you need to
talk to someone to talk to another
person i'm like wow sure yeah i mean
okay yeah so i i guess i i neglected to
mention i i touched on it but yeah i
joined my night media management company
uh last year and stuff so that was that
was talking with my managers overnight
media so
i get i mean i i don't i don't know
lingualized if they're considered part
of my team because
yeah but they are part of my team yeah
they they've been infinitely helpful and
they've provided so much value and so
much guidance it's been great so what do
they do for you
um they pitch out you know
they find sponsors and stuff they find
opportunities um you know they connect
you know like like us and stuff or
podcasts they did a lot of collabs more
clout like was going to like collabs
last year um film some like from some
shows uh you know like
like we like got the the c3 um the
pokeballs that were launching like they
were the ones that kind of had those
connections and pitched
i guess myself out there so no they've
been you know they've been very helpful
in that regards and also just giving
guidance you know um
just like little things like just
talking with reed and nick over at night
meet about like focusing on average view
duration and getting those up because my
my videos were
they pop in and they leave and and so my
average view racing's low is how do you
get that up so that it hits the
algorithm better and
the cpms go up and all that stuff so
just you know it's like looking at
thumbnails and being like why would you
do that or this like you should do this
and just like being a mentor in many
aspects as far as like especially the
business side but also just in general
just being successful on youtube how is
that for you let's say because
i would kind of think to myself if you
built up a channel to 10 million it
would be really hard for me to take
advice
because i'm like well obviously what i
was doing was working could it be better
after everything could always be better
but if it's working so far
i i take everything with a grain of salt
and i think that's also part of the
reason why it's been hard for me to
expand a little bit because i've been so
in like if i hire if i'm hiring somebody
it's not too
like
do something that's
like
like i don't know i couldn't even think
of an example like like an accountant
like hey can you balance my books or
something yes it's like hey can you hire
somebody to edit the videos that i've
been editing for 12 years and make it
similar to the style and whatever
standards i have and being able to sit
with that and be content with that and i
think that's kind of been a mental block
for me
which
you know again always just trying to
keep an open mind and be progressive
constantly learning and stuff because
like i kind of said you know they
provided so much value and so much
insight and things that they've that
we've that i've implemented
through their guidance and stuff has
been great it has worked out
fantastically so
i'm i'm not a no at all yeah no by any
means i'm not going to pretend
that that that's the case so um yeah i
was always down to learn i was trying to
improve now i saw one interesting video
i want to bring up um it was the youtube
originals that you did yes the eating
challenge and i saw a video
reviewing the eating challenge i saw
that i watched those two yeah
yeah i don't know whatever that video it
popped off yeah because it was like your
face almost crying in the thumbnail have
you seen this
and i remember clicking on it it was
like oh no what happened i'm thinking
like it's this matrix i know
i was nervous watching i was nervous too
i was scared for you and i click on it
oh
geez
but it's you do see your face it made
sense and it made sense
i felt bad
i really felt bad me too
like i was watching and this guy's
explaining i'm like i mean whether or
not what he's saying was true with we
resonated with you but the way that he
phrased it so everyone would understand
this yeah you did a youtube originals
thing where basically you get people
that like
do make certain types of content on
youtube like very successful people and
then they have like other youtubers that
aren't successful within that given
niche or whatever try to do what they do
for example one of them i think like uh
for let's just use your example like was
competitive eating so they got you and
you judged these other people that don't
make youtube videos around competitive
eating try to eat competitively right
and they were kind of i won't say making
a mockery of it one of them but one of
them was more than the other yes true
but i will say they weren't taking it as
seriously as they were taking the other
challenges sure the competitive eating
because it
to them maybe it seemed like it was so
like like absurd to dip you know bread
and water and stuff like that you know
maybe it is
you know it can be absurd i guess in in
some context but but yeah it didn't seem
like they took it very seriously and you
looked very disheartened because i'm
sure that you put a lot of time and
effort into you know showing up there
and maybe you're nervous to show up and
then they go and they you know don't try
very hard yeah i mean i mean the format
of the show was it was the four
contestants and they all kind of had
their own
day of having the other ones try their
own thing
and then i was like the finale so i
think mine was a surprise i don't think
they expected to do anything competitive
eating related and stuff um
yeah i mean i
i'll say this much i wasn't as bummed
out about it as i think a lot of the
comments and stuff were and just like
the comments were backing you up crazy i
appreciate it
yeah which i i totally get and i see a
vantage point like personally when i was
sitting there in the moment it was weird
you know it was like watching people
throw hot dog buns
yeah and and stuff and not do what i was
doing like
but i guess and you know
i get it it i mean part of the fun of
watching someone dunk a hot dog bun for
the first time is because it's gross
yeah you know so yeah so i mean i wasn't
as bummed out i know i know where the
perspective was coming from do i wish
they would have tried better definitely
yeah well like i did i did um i did a
collab with the try guys not to
not too far apart from each other and a
couple of those guys they were trying
like yeah i think it was keith and um
but um
two of them were going at it going at it
and then a couple of them were like you
know so gingerly
so
everybody's got their own thing and i'm
i'm understanding of that they're
jumping into my world which is kind of
intense and crazy so
everybody react differently
unfortunately
them they didn't they didn't they didn't
vibe with the competitive eating natures
as much as we would have probably liked
them too but uh
you know it was fun to be part of the
whole production and everything but a
little more effort would have been yeah
well we're here to make it right because
we're getting the spiciest chicken yes
okay i'm keeping an eye on it on that
note this not better be the next video
oh you guys took a little nibble that's
chicken sandwich no it gave up no i'm
going there all right another 20 minutes
20 25 minutes it'll be here i'm nervous
yeah
but i but speaking of that i would be
the type i hate i'm just going to admit
it i would be the type to be very
gingerly about how i'm going to dip um
because i don't eat like i i can't do
that i can eat like if i'm really hungry
yeah and i'll scarf the food down but
forcing it
um i just notice i get like stomach
issues i'm a fast eater i'm known
amongst my friend group as the fast
eater like like i'll finish my meal
before someone has like gotten like way
through or whatever but that's a
complete different thing than actual
like dipping it in water yeah i mean
yeah yeah i mean it's a mindset i've
seen some people just like pop up out of
nowhere and just do
good at an eating contest because
it's it's a weird switch it's you've
eaten your own whole life you chew your
food you swallow it after you've chewed
it enough and there's no real inherent
rush generally unless you're like you
know like lunch break or something
um so you're kind of going against your
natural grain of something you've done
literally since your whole life yeah
some people have that you could just
turn it off and for me it's like like
like i work out but power lifters i
couldn't do that like i just feel like
my arms are gonna fall off and i just
can't imagine getting swole and ripped
and just lifting 450 pounds like i just
couldn't i just can't fathom doing that
some people
they like doing that and it's their
thing and they can turn that switch so
some people got it some people don't but
i think it's mental i i think if you
mentally focus you can just make it
happen what does your diet look like
after an eating competition because
let's say you pack down like 10 000
calories how many calories would you say
is in one of those challenges i mean
challenges vary like you know some of
them are ten thousand some of them are
just a quick five thousand six thousand
somewhere over twenty thousand
it's boring
it's a boring diet yeah you know it's
mainly water is your best friend
because um your body can handle your
body can decide to handle calories
in its own way like not to be gross
about it but your body can only
physically absorb so many calories
that's just the way it works
but vitamins and minerals
your body doesn't have a choice for the
most part that's why dehydration is a
thing like you just your body can't say
no i don't want to deal with the salt
the salt is going to be there it's going
to be in the bloodstream it's going to
dehydrate you you're going to need more
so i also balance it out like if i do a
sweets challenge or something even
though i don't need more calories i'd
definitely like
to get a protein shake in or something
or
have a burger or a steak or something
you know it seems weird to eat after
eating so much but you want to achieve
that balance with your body because it's
the imbalance that throws your system
off
um like i said water's your best friend
i take various supplements certain
electrolytes and stuff just again just
for that balance and
when i started it was brutal just to get
dehydrated and stuff nowadays i just
blow up like a little balloon i got this
like like literally it's like i think
it's just
like
like all the salts and waters and stuff
to get into your tissues like
edema i i forget the phrase but it's
just the swelling of the tissue and but
but how are you in shape
like i said i don't feel like i'm in
shape see but you look in shape yeah
like you look more toned than i do when
i go to the gym yeah it's all that
editing i'm just there yeah i know i
mean
yeah i mean i go to the gym you know so
i i i like to run and stuff it's kind of
a full body workout in some some ways so
yeah i don't know i mean i think it is i
mean i guess okay i guess a good way to
put it is it's out of necessity
if i wasn't taking care of myself if i
wasn't physically in great shape then i
wouldn't be able to physically compete
at a high level sure
and my body wouldn't like
it wouldn't
accept all the
the pressure and the training and stuff
that makes sense i have to i have to be
in shape like that's why a lot of people
ask competitive eaters like why is
everybody like skinny like the
kobayashi's of the road like mickey even
joey like he's you know he's a big guy
but he's in shape you know whereas
30 years ago there was a bunch of dudes
on coney island that were like 400
pounds and stuff and it's because when
it became
serious you had to say like you have the
cardio breathing and
it's exhausting it's a 10-minute sprint
when you're up here on stage so speaking
of like you know being in shape and and
you know that stuff um
this is a little bit controversial in
the youtube community but
what are your thoughts on like
nicotine avocado and that whole
okay
so i'll
i'll preface by saying this i've got
zero like the mukbang community and
everything like
it's different from what i do like i
kind of said earlier like competitive
eating youtubers like you're not
competing with people it's like you know
that lingo like you know
snub those links if you want to call it
but um
no i got absolutely zero problem with
like the asmr community even even though
it's not my
thing like
they are making entertainment for a
group of people and that's that's all it
boils down to some people want to hear
people smacking on a peanut butter jelly
some people want to see people just
talking and eating
some people want to see you eat it as
fast as possible right you just you're
filling the need you're filling like i
don't like some movies some people like
you know everybody's got their own
preference so i got no quarrels with it
nicotto um
took it too far that's all it is he he
he found a formula that unfortunately um
i don't even know i mean i guess outside
looking in unfortunately worked for him
very well
and he just stoked that fire constantly
without worry about repercussions he's
probably still doing pretty good
and i mean at the end of the day
it's his his body it's his choice it's
his
if he's fine with it fine i mean you
know but
would i endorse that
i'd always endorse people being healthy
looking out for their physical and
mental health and all that stuff for
those of you guys that don't understand
uh nico cotto basically started out as
like a fairly skinny you know somewhat
fit person
just
yeah
yeah i think there's a vegan stuff yeah
and then basically would do like mukbang
which is when you get a bunch of food
and eat it and people like watching you
do that different than competitive
eating yeah and uh and basically like he
continued to do it because his audience
loved it and he continued growing uh
with what's like absurdism type of humor
and then like now he's pretty like you
know he's pretty large you know what i
think i'll give my take on this um
i think i part of me believes it's an
act i mean part of me thinks that he's
playing a a character and uh
i don't know why i found his entire
story like so fascinating and i've
reached out to him i think once before
to see if he'd come on the podcast no
response back i don't think that's ever
gonna happen okay i would love to get
him on the podcast yeah because i found
it so fascinating i've watched so many
of those like nicocado avocado like the
rise and fall videos i've watched them
all and they're so good they're really
good but he's one of those people that
has such an interesting story and like
and it's just it fascinates me of like
how you don't know how much of his how
much is an act if he's really this way
if he's playing into it
um
uh like it reminds me with dax flame
yeah how a lot of people thought oh he's
just it's it's acting and you know uh
but for me i was like no that just seems
like dax and and sure enough it was it
was just him like that's him with
nicocado i'm like that i think it's an
act and from what i've seen it seems as
though he realized a certain action got
him a lot of attention on youtube and
that made him a decent amount of money
so you would lean into that yeah and it
seems like the more extreme he's gotten
the more money he makes the more views
he gets and the more subscribers he gets
so from a business it's like why
wouldn't you keep going in that
direction
and on youtube you can never like
not
continue to push yourself you can never
go back from that like if he stopped
doing that content i'm sure yes people
would be happy for him but would that
give him the same views probably not
um so even though he gets a lot of
people watching me like oh wow this is a
train wreck and just tune in for that at
the end of the day like when you look at
his numbers he's winning from it so the
more it works i think the more he's
going to do it uh the downside is that
it's probably at the detriment of his
health oh yeah but
you know if he's at a point where he's
like well if i do this for another five
years and then i have the rest of my
life to get back into shape and if you
think something like that
maybe
that's the only way i see it yeah i mean
maybe it's i mean
i could be wrong but without question in
my mind it is at least in some part an
act like there's no way that he's
actually like that all day long like it
takes a special person certainly yeah
he does yeah but he's definitely leaning
into what the audience and like i i
think back to him you know
i think back to like you know stuff like
the logan paul drama and stuff like his
justification was he was just on this
this
this train that he just didn't want to
stop and then it ended up you know
bad decisions and stuff and yeah i mean
that's that's that's just the nature of
a lot of beasts like that type of
happened um which was leading to a
question i wanted to ask you because
i haven't seen any drama that you've
particularly been involved in stuff
which is something that i prided myself
over the years too and i
every once in a while i want to see like
the nicocados of the world or certain
like um
like like the rice gums yeah all that
stuff like
i don't want to i'm not jealous yeah but
there's that part of you that's just
like am i doing something wrong here do
you ever get that itch no controversy
what's this
not listen
any sort of drama for the most part yes
it's good in the short time i think in
the bad time long term it's bad
and i've tried
a lot of it is it's it's bad for someone
well logan paul between two people it's
bad for what what
you know the whole issue yeah i mean
look at look at him now people love to
watch well that's his personal growth
it's like as long as you can prove to
people you're changed and you're
different but you don't love it but you
could change and not go through that
like if you have the choice to work on
yourself and better yourself without
that i would much rather do it without
that
i don't i don't think but what if what
if that's at the sacrifice of you know
not being yourself because you're a
little bit edgy you know lately it seems
as though like the higher the stakes get
like like the the more you put yourself
out there the bigger the risk there
becomes that you say the wrong thing
even unintentionally but yeah i mean i
mean like you know to me it's
interesting because you know you see
um these these case studies of people
who have turned it into something that's
you know interesting and stuff and like
i'm a big ufc fan i go out to a lot of
their fights and everything and the
biggest draws are the guys that just
talk and just yeah mcgregor
part of the charm of charm if you want
to call it is you kind of know that
that's not them
i think
you see a lot of people like colby
covington just did a fight and he's all
like
maggot hat trumps he's like this
ridiculous character and people hate him
for it like like the floyd mayweather
too yeah yeah he wasn't doing anything
until he started flaunting his money and
they were like
here's the haters and stuff and people
just kept buying this fight because they
wanted to see them knocked on the floor
nelk and danny duncan it makes sense
with their brand you know that they'd be
so erratic and knelt just did a podcast
with donald trump yeah
i saw it it was removed did you watch i
did not want i don't know
uh yeah they put it on their oh you
didn't know this
what yeah oh you didn't know it got
removed got removed for what five
million views um
disinformation
i thought missing
information and that's funny because
trump said in the podcast that it will
be that it's going to get removed yeah
um so digressing i mean i'm just i'm
curious because that's something that
i've i
i've very thankfully avoided drama and
just the nicki minaj i just think the
big like no one will care if you get 10
000 views on a video or you have you
know 100 000 subscribers it's not worth
anyone's attention let's say but when
you get into the larger numbers and more
people watch it becomes uh
uh easier not easier but there's more
eyeballs on you and the chances that
someone will find something is higher so
if that's why it like at least from my
perspective the the more the channel's
grown the more careful i've become as a
result and i think also too it kind of
leads into like what your intentions
with youtube and just in general yeah if
you're looking to build a brand like my
case you know i do the competitive
eating like i want to keep doing this
and i want like i like making videos
um then why would you risk it and stuff
because i i remember seeing
you know certain people come and go and
stuff and yeah like like
yes you get jealous of like you know
i've seen people on billboards and stuff
like oh mac man what are they doing
right that i need to do or like just to
like make get to the next level but at
the same time like i've been able to do
this for 12 years and i'm still doing
okay you know and stuff so
it's always it's just one of those
things where you're just always thinking
about like you know but yeah yeah you've
surpassed the lifespan of like most
youtubers at this point because when i
first started i'm like almost everyone
that i ever watched was five to seven
years and and if they hit seven
they they've done it like that was like
that's age 90 like that's like a 90 year
old person in like youtube time yeah you
know so seven years is a long time but
the past ten is almost like unheard of
and then to go beyond that it's just
it's a small group yeah i mean i didn't
start as soon as like the philip
defrancos like he wasn't before me and
everything but you know it's it's you
know there's a pride involved with it
and
you know
at the same time you know you always
want to feel like you're just getting
started i mean like you know just like
we talked about your bankroll coffee and
stuff and like establishing those brands
and just like really learning the space
and taking advantage of the opportunity
yeah you don't want that to stop
speaking of which you know before we get
our taste buds annihilated um i heard
that you have a pokeball line coming out
and it's similar to like a a mr beast
burger where people are going to be able
to order and stuff is am i getting that
right yeah how did you come up with that
idea that was knight media
yeah so um a um a large restaurant
company um they're they're working on
launching a brand it's called c3 um
and they're working with a bunch of
creators not just myself like danny
duncan met him at the pokemon thing he's
launching the chicken sandwich and stuff
and so a lot of it was like hey like
what's the type of food that you eat
what's the type of stuff that you like
like um
and how can we like convert that into
what would be now like ghost kitchens
like mr beast burger
and um
back and forth you know but i grew up on
rice bowls like i love eating rice bowls
i spent a lot of time in hawaii my
parents met in hawaii so we visit there
a lot
and pokeballs just it worked out great
with the company they got a good supply
chain for high quality fish and rice and
everything so
yeah we're launching stony bowls
hopefully in the sometime in the near
future super excited about it yeah and
um yeah we did bring some
whole plethora i'm excited drove all the
way down mandalay beta pick those up
before here and bring them over
see i see i don't know why i thought you
would have like an assistant go and pick
this up you personally wouldn't you i
was surprised you came here alone yeah a
little late no
but like you know they'll show up with
like an assistant or a videographer or
something like that you're like a lawyer
sitting in the room or something does
that ever happen close yeah
it's kind of awkward because we'll ask a
question then
yeah and i answer this yeah that's how
they're like yeah we would rather you
not yeah sorry i can't like i heard them
you don't have to
say it
graham you said that uh when you did a
video with kevin o'leary he was just
himself right yeah he just showed up
kevin he didn't have a driver he didn't
have an assistant he drove the car
himself and just walked up with a
briefcase it was incredible i was so
sorry i arrived in a nice car though he
took an audi no no no he got dropped off
into numerolox oh he did i thought he
drove himself no i remember seeing
something he always does reluctantly
all right okay
but sometimes
you would you would most expect to show
up with an entourage or like an
assistant or somebody show up just alone
exactly and then yeah and then people
who uh you would expect to show up alone
show up with like oh by the way i'm with
five people yeah is that cool and i'm
like oh my god
yeah yeah
see the aquarium yeah
okay well should we try some chewing i
wasn't even thinking like if we're going
to do a spicy challenge we got to get
something in our stomach right it would
burn so much harder if you don't get
something so
what did what did you bring and by the
way could you walk us through really
quick
how much money you make from this what
are the i'm so curious what the profit
margins on this because i'll tell you
with coffee
if i make a dollar a bag well right now
i'm not making any money but uh
if i made a dollar a bag i mean it's
just
that would be considered good i mean
this is pre-launch and this is the
infrastructure and stuff is all being
taken care of by c3 um i get like i
think like the deal was like a small
stake and stuff so it's not really like
a profit thing the most part
an opportunity to be part of something
bigger got it because a lot of there's
like i forget how many creators are on
the roster but it's a pretty big list
so um so yeah is danny with night media
i don't think so okay which was was
weird to see him at the pokemon event i
know he's just really into pokemon i
never knew that i never took him as a
pokemon guy either yeah because like the
stunts
yeah we uh
we got dinner a while ago this is right
after logan paul's video came out uh
about the pokemon cards
and danny was collecting psa 10
charizards first edition yeah
and he said he bought like he bought
like several sets and stuff like that
wow
oh my gosh
where'd you get these from i don't oh
sorry i don't want to interrupt your
story wow anyway well you got to get
them all across the country oh my god
delivery
can you get some b-roll of that with
your phone just so that people i have
extras too i got i've got two of each
bowl so if you need to get any shots
later
holy [ __ ] oh he said the s-word again
this is this this space is totally new
to me i thought when opportunity came up
like this sounds so great but the more
we worked with c3 in making this product
it blew my mind how
the product that we came up with and on
top of that too we're also with it
relenting giant mortar giant bowl with
all of these in one thing too so that's
such that's so on brand can we get
chopsticks or so wait so i'm so curious
so when you pull up at mandalay bay do
they know who you are and they're like
oh wow he's picking up his own food yeah
they're they're a humongous company they
own so many uh they have they own kumi
operator kumi or the mandalay bay are
you gonna eat with us yeah of course
okay so let me just real quick so let me
just go over here so what is this
i'm so hungry
are you guys pokey fans yes that's
graham and i we try to uh have a date
once every week and we usually get poke
yeah really yeah cause jack moved out
and uh we stopped seeing each other
never see him anymore and it's a bad
thing he texts me when he's at the gym
instead of giving me something notice
yep okay well you know i won't get in
your way starting that right there is
our chicken teriyaki bowl it's you know
it's a standard chicken teriyaki you
know just chicken breasts
you know sauteed onions and stuff hey
you can let him the uh but we knew has
delivered there we go we're getting our
prep ready perfect timing oh my god holy
oh my
are you kidding me houston
but like you
you it's
the whole thing is filled with
everything no it's not look at this dude
oh my this is like honestly i feel like
i'm in a dream right now
i i get the vibe that you haven't like
eaten on podcast before now you've got
like a buffet yeah this is
everything
i'm i'm i'm actually having well no i'm
not gonna call him mukbang but i'm
eating a lot of food in a competitive
manner with matt stoney this is a dream
this is oyakodon this is something i
grew up eating it's chicken egg
it's like an adashi broth it's just kind
of awesome it's a home comfort food
that's the signature poke bowl that
we're releasing
it's ahi tuna with what i think
places miss all the time which is sesame
oil
sesame oil marinade it makes so much
when i had it it made sense but just
like how many seared ahi things have you
seen with like sesame seeds on it it's
just the perfect combination so you know
you know what i count this as right now
matt
so imagine if we had like
um
imagine if we had like a famous
basketball playing around you know we
play basketball with him this is the
same thing i'm eating really uh with
matt stoney right yeah yeah this is the
same thing granted we're flattered i
know we're not it's weird for me because
i'm just chilling out just
having dinner before spicy challenge but
so i i stopped by jack in the box before
here okay and i grabbed three junior
bacon cheeseburgers because i wanted to
race okay that was the surprise yeah i
wanted to race you
but i mean
i'm still down well of course you're
down man because you can't eat anything
i i'll be able to i'll be able to put it
down yeah
we'll see how we're feeling i mean
i'm down but i've a phone for for if we
put an effort into the spicy challenge
maybe we'll do it before the spicy sure
but i i have to race you i've been
telling myself that i'm gonna do this
since we knew you were coming on baby
bucket list type of thing yeah serious
gotta happen it has to yep
try that that's my favorite one yeah so
that's that's the panko shrimp with the
wasabi aioli and wasabi peas in case you
don't want to share something we've got
plenty i wanted to bring plenty this is
uh an oyakodon oyako is japanese for
parent and child it's it's something i
grew up on because it's it's uh chicken
thigh and egg it's like a scramble with
the dashi broth and they cook it all
together
um
grilled onions and everything and then
you just top it on rice it's a comfort
food it's nothing
like super fancy or something but it's
just
to me at least it's a comfort food
we get pokey probably like once to twice
a week
and
this one was probably my favorite with
the spicy sauce i've not tried this one
yet the tuna
tastes really really really fresh but
the good thing with the tuna macy that
he was explaining is that they put
sesame oil on it which is what yeah
that's right like a lot of poke places
missing is usually just like use like a
basic ponzu or shoyu or something
that sesame oil makes it kind of rich
adds that nutty flavor and then of
course you do also have a ponzu you know
sesame sauce on top of it to add that
that traditional flavor i grew up eating
a lot of rice bowls and poke and stuff
so
i'm hoping that this this this nails it
a little bit it's my attempt to nail it
so
i still think i forget where i saw it
but um
like home automation i was just looking
into and stuff and somebody had posted
this thing where they showed their if
this and that thing and it's like if
like if like
the alarm goes off like it's like
somebody breaking into the house it's
like alexa just like turn off all the
lights
and then turn all the lights beat red
and start blasting music really loud and
stuff and i was like that's actually
really smart that would be freaky if you
just i think they three high quality
speakers somewhere in the house
going off at different points the
shotgun noise you're like oh yeah
shotgun noises yeah well that's what
yeah simply safe does something similar
to that though
not the shotgun noise but simply say it
doesn't it no simply safe has it where
the alarms go off uh then there's you
know but yeah but we're not i guess
that's like everything
i'm talking like red lights yeah yeah
boss music
so we had the scariest thing happen last
night with macy and i and uh anytime you
open a door or a window
our alarm goes
every single time and it's always my
fear that it's like it'll be one o'clock
in the morning yeah we're in bed we're
about to fall asleep and there's
goes off that's my biggest fear last
night it was like almost midnight
and the entire house was locked up and
we hear that
and both of us freeze and i'm like i i
thought someone was in the house so the
first thing i was like check this check
the camera because we have a camera in
the front messy go check yeah check it
out i'll stay here and take care of
bailey you go look no but i went the to
the bedroom door and i locked it and
then once the door was locked i knew
we'd like at least have a few seconds in
there
it was like the cat's out there
what am i going to do i don't know where
he is
i would run out just to save the cat
like i would be like ramsay could be
anywhere yeah but they're not going to
attack a cat
i mean you don't know no you're not
right in the head to break into
someone's
cat's not going to call the cop
something
target your danger to the cat exactly
yeah
but anyway so i locked the door and i
didn't see any motion on the ring camera
in front so i'm like
it's not somebody in front
and so we check the camera and we don't
see anything and ramsay uh we see ramsay
on the camera he's like all perked up
and we're like oh [ __ ] what what what is
it so i check the uh the side door and
it's open and we think you were gonna go
out front i was like we'll wait one
second and go to the side door and it's
just open oh yeah it's open by like a
little bit by like that much but it was
locked it was locked but you saw the
lock out so i guess when it locked it
didn't lock all the way in and the wind
blew it open
but anyway that was the deep yeah it was
scary so now from now on i'm so scared
that at night i'm going to hear that
sound you remember
do you remember when we were like about
to go to bed and this is after jack
moved out
and we hear someone walking through the
house and you know oh my god and then
you came out there and it was jack
jack you gotta text us if you're coming
jack didn't turn on any of the lights
it's just like this oh yeah oh yeah yeah
i remember and i was nervous walking and
i'm like i hope i don't scare graham
i was thinking that to myself yeah like
i'm walking and i'm like i hope he
doesn't come out cause i'm gonna scare
him
i don't even think we were expecting him
it wasn't like he was expect we were
expecting him that night to show up for
an sd card or anything it was just like
all the time so funny yeah i was worried
about scaring you i was like okay i'll
just try this 11 o'clock at night no
yeah oh my bad
sorry
graham's very paranoid because he's
always like alex if you're going to come
just uh just text because yeah now i
make sure you can't you can't just show
up anymore right if you live here right
then it's kind of assumed
did you feel safer when i was in the
house or not yeah i would change shell
jack ready then yeah gekko check it out
it's a third person that will throw you
off i mean if attacker comes in there's
three again three versus two true
we're better off with three right and
you gotta think too like for an attacker
to come in if they weren't expecting you
to be in the house but they knew that we
were there then you're like this secret
hidden person that's gonna like bruce
willis this yeah see i always made sure
as a as a kid i mean i don't i'm not
mindful of it anymore but as a kid i
would always never i would never want
the room that's closest to the front
door i always wanted my brother to be
window yeah exactly like you never
wanted to be closest to the front door
because
as this makes you sound evil but if they
get someone it's not you it's something
yeah i always thought that um
if you if you i i guess the way the bed
faces i never wanted to sleep away from
the door yeah because in that way you
couldn't see it coming yeah at least you
can see it yeah right
it's one of you made aware yeah i opened
my eyes and it's like okay now i know
something's happening okay yeah i just i
just want to sleep with a frying pan in
the room because i know if anyone came i
can i got a pretty good swing like that
that's a good song i got a baseball bat
by the way right after that did you
really because i realized my mom bought
one too yeah like yeah it's the brooklyn
crusher defender bat i got all right i
did seriously i went on amazon and typed
in baseball bat self-defense and that
was the number one thing was the
brooklyn defender probably dude that's
hilarious i just saw that in my mom's
shopping cart on amazon he saw it and i
was shopping
what why do you check your mom's
shopping cart because i have the same
login as them
am i allowed to say that publicly
katonic okay yeah the tonic baseball bat
28-inch self-defense black it just seems
so imp it's like why would you want a
baseball bat you're better
no you realize how close you have to get
to someone with a taser
hey that's a stun gun i'm talking a
taser that's a taser no the taser is the
one that you shoot you know but
for a taser to actually work and this is
like weird stuff i know both prongs
actually have to hit and the further
away the target is the harder it is to
hit even for typical like
self-defense things they say really
don't pull out a taser unless there's
somebody else with a backup weapon just
by not sure
but not to be grotesque but if you're
really trying to protect yourself
a machete is going to
clearly
unless they take unless they take that
from you and then they turn on you and
what about the okay what about the bat
it's like the same thing it's like just
don't get it taken from you if they get
it taken from you you're done either way
hit by a pillow in the back that's where
i'm at team frying pan here because if
someone tries to hit you the frying pan
is also good as a shield
as well as a weapon like you know if
somebody tried to hit you with like a
knife then you could yeah but here's the
thing man stop it if okay look look i
don't want to put myself in the shoes of
the intruder but i will just for the
sake of the argument okay so don't think
of me as an intruder but okay so let's
say i'm going into a house okay i'm
intruding on okay and then i turn around
the corner and i see macy there with a
frying pan i'm like okay
let's say let's say she gets a hit on me
okay i can grab that frying pan out of
her hand right but if i turn the corner
and i see her with a machete or a like a
katana i'm like definitely not getting
close to her because even if she hits me
once i'm done if you're holding even a
baseball bat it's like i can take a hit
to the ba i just rushed it you know
you do you have to think if you did
break into the house and somebody had a
machete or katana you'd be like oh they
are wow they are a freak yeah
actually you could buy one on on amazon
for 22 yeah get naked and have a katana
and then they're like
there's no yeah
that's horrifying i got one no you got a
what a machete
you bought a machete
did you actually buy it
yeah
on monday wait what about the katana
wait oh my god you actually got a
machete yeah graham here's our new
tactic
you go out with the baseball bat if
there's someone there and you're like
look my girlfriend's here she's gotta
miss chetty she's a little crazy i would
just suggest you leave and then i come
up behind you like catch up real nice
that's what you say
i've been waiting for this one
graham you've brought me a good one
today tag team anyway because you could
never be like because after that i did
realize if we're in the bedroom we have
nothing to protect ourselves with the
only option is to run and uh you know i
figured well between
not having a baseball bat not having a
machete i'd rather have both right at
least not both of you guys can be
equipped you know
yeah the frying pan is too far away so
yeah i could talk about this stuff for
hours
what you must know dedicated
self-defense dad was flipping out when
we were watching um
what show was it they were going over
like
how they found certain serial killers
and stuff and he clicks onto one i'm
like oh this is that case and he's like
within like 30 seconds of the things
starting i'm like oh this is this one
this is the whole case and he was like
how do you know and i'm like i just know
some people are into that stuff
yeah it's yeah i mean i don't want to
say it's concerning but mason is way too
much about serial killers and like how
people like you know on alive and stuff
and it's just she'll be like oh yeah but
he poisoned this or she did that and
like i was like okay disproportionately
serial killers probably know about other
serial killers disproportionately yeah
oh like like just just putting this out
there but like to throw up over blood
because i i didn't know that
to throw
we were watching a show i feel like i'm
like
this is uncomfortable but um
we were watching this show and um what
is it called on netflix anyways this
girl had a blood stain on her carpet and
i was like well they can go over that
with luminol later because when you do
luminol and you spray it on there it
will glow because of the dna when that
reacts under a black light so um it will
show where blood is or more
accurately dna so that could come from a
lot of different things i'm like i
wonder if she wanted to throw that to
kind of throw people off from that if
she could just throw up over that and
then kind of cover up this thing and
then he was like what the heck but the
reason why i know so much about this is
because i wanted to go into uh the fbi
okay but it wouldn't allow me to have
any of the other life goals i wanted
so for me it was a lot more important to
have kids and a family
but i like i would love to just track
down
missing people and like get answers for
people right i just i'm fascinated but i
want to catch that stuff so bad that's
why i know yeah i mean it's it's a
valuable it's like i think my brother
he's he's using the cars he doesn't he
does some work his car stuff
i don't know anything about cars but as
soon as something happens to the car
he's right there and he just figures it
out so in case something happens and
you got it covered yeah
right now you know i'm cuz i'm full now
actually yeah i did i did bring a
surprise
and i wanted to to do this on the
podcast
okay you me and matt what
comp oh you i mean you could stay here
basically hey graham you should get that
you should get the mic okay
you gotta you gotta stay here macy to
cheer on yeah your boyfriend i'm not
gonna do any competition yes you are
no no no you're not that full because
what do they say matt about being
maybe they say something it's mentality
and mentality
there we go okay
now i know you're pretty strong mentally
graham okay and we're gonna test that
out right now because i brought
looks like french fries
jack in the box
so what we're gonna be doing
is we're all going to race each other
are you serious jack
junior it's a junior bit it's not even
baking
everything else would you rather get
full off of pokey
i'm not going to slander jack in the box
right now but
i've been eating so healthy
i've been i've been counting my calories
now for well
i'll tell you what if you want
um
matt can try to beat me two to one if
you want if you want to do i'll take a
few bites i'll
give her your best friend you're gonna
take a few bites man we love
jack-in-the-box thank you jackie
i bought this off your vip jack cash by
the way i'm running out so if you guys
send me another one that would be much
appreciated on real quick just just to
wrap it up uh stony bolts
or something they got this out so i just
wanted to do a solitude storyboard super
excited about it see are you gonna be
dipping this in the water and stuff are
you just gonna
dry eat it
i don't think this is a dip situation
okay what kind of situation is messy um
burgers are hard because the
the part that would absorb it it's kind
of on the inside yeah so
see i'm just nervous um about a choking
and
and b biting my tongue
that could happen it happens um
i don't know how you get around that
okay so there's no okay so what i'm
gonna what i'm probably gonna do is i'm
probably just gonna fold it in half and
squeeze it oh yeah just make it is make
it as small as possible just
er and just really and just chomp at it
yeah see i'm nervous although i know i
have no cha like chance against you i'm
still nervous because i wanted it
anything could happen yeah we'll see and
and water's your best friend don't
forget the waters there okay oh god i'm
a throw up i know something's gonna
happen
all right round two here we go
how are you eating this i'm probably
just gonna fold it in half and it's
gonna like like make it like a taco one
are you gonna drink it while eating it
i mean it's like it's like a chaser it's
like boom boom boom that's what i'm
probably doing oh my gosh count down
somebody yeah three
two
one go
oh my god no
oh
done
how much do you guys have left stop jack
stop show the camera
okay so uh jack made it further yeah
putting some work in there
what why did you reorder it because you
said you're supposed to
fold it in half to make it go faster
that's what i was doing just get the air
bubbles out of the
bread we don't have a timer but here we
go here we go
jack looks committed for the finish
let's get him
let him get there
reasonably clear mouth just
there we go
[Laughter]
oh my god there we go
that was under
what 15 for me oh you know it tastes
incredible you taste it yeah you taste
the food people wonder that sometimes
but thanks jack in the box i'll take
another vip jack cash that was some good
fun they say they commonly say
competitive eating isn't pretty but it's
beautiful so i felt beautiful when i was
doing it exactly
you didn't feel pretty you feel
beautiful it's interesting the water
with that because the water was almost
weird because i took a bite and then
drank yeah
oh you're killing it man
that was like a slap
so i have to explain what this is
it's a it's a one of a kind in the world
this is the
spiciest
sandwich ever
at two million scoville units
now now if we look at like the scoville
chart i think it's like
uh a pepper is something like you know
50 or something like that this is two
million jalapenos eight thousand looks
delicious it looks good yeah very normal
smell it i've seen more intimidating
spicy challenges
i don't even smell it
no it doesn't really
let's matt smell it nothing really no
it's just me maybe i got a really
sensitive nose i don't have great senses
maybe i
my nostrils aren't burning but i know i
could i could i could it smells spicy no
the spice is there yeah the psychology
that i have behind spicy challenge is
interesting because
it's not going to kill you
right it's just it's just pain and it's
not going to okay it's not going to kill
you it's not going to damage you right
it like so just it's like a mental test
it's really like oh wait it's like
it's just like just do it thank you for
those words maybe just turn them oh
sorry it might just
like burning
underneath my nails where i ripped it
off here so
oh just one thing just i learned the
hard way
do not rub your eyes whatever you do oh
yes
matt says do not rub your eyes guys
probably a good idea okay don't even use
napkins sure avoid it all right
oh yeah that's sad
holy [ __ ] that's bad it's like eating um
like tabasco yeah
but if someone
took it and like ground it up and i
don't know if that is it made it really
bad all right matt apparently apparently
he gets worse
you're you're tearing up
yeah
this would be the time to take
thumbnails yeah yeah
yeah crying are we splitting this up are
we trying to cut it i i don't care to
take a bite after you talk
i'll take it wait you know what do you
want me to take a bite yeah you go for
it let me let me go let me go first
because macy got a bite
hold on
that's it yes what's it no
oh
i don't i don't do well with it it's
burning my gums fyi
it's burning my gums how bad pretty bad
[Music]
okay
come on
[Applause]
water makes it worse do not do that i
want water so bad right now but it makes
it worse
here oh milk you want some oatmeal no
i've never seen you like this gram
are you okay just give it a second okay
i probably make it get out to be worse
than it actually is
you next or me next oh whatever you want
man listen if i could do it it's
ow that's why are you clenching your
heart man
because my esophagus burns i don't know
what to do because they took a little
nugget thing but i feel like i gotta do
more than that but you know what yeah
the thing is is you just get all of the
spice with that you don't get any
chicken yeah it feels really hot but the
hard part for me is it feels like my
mouth has a pulse right now
oh god but i feel it here and i'm not
sure if it's because i don't have i feel
like i need water
dang i don't think water health i don't
think it makes it worse it just doesn't
help you need lactose or
alcohol you guys have no um it seems
like maybe that was no i mean that kind
of helps it feels good i feel like
alcohol before would also be good too
i mean
alcohol neutralizes capsaicin in the
same way that lactose does so well see i
was going to take a like a big bite of
the burger that's what i thought we were
doing but now i see that and they're
like they look like they're in disrepair
it's concerning yeah it's uh
graham keeps saying ow i don't look like
i'm in disrepair graham looks like he's
in disrepair i am fine my nose just
won't stop running but he's not
clenching his heart but yes my it's like
you feel it my esophagus i don't know
why like i feel maybe there's a part
stuck in there it's burns right like
right there
yeah it's just burning your tissue i
think that's
that's all it is it's i think i think it
i think it's a it's uh it's supposed to
be like a defense mechanism plants and
stuff they develop this so people don't
eat it and look at us now we're stuffing
it down right
see you've got me nervous i kind of wish
i went first now because then i at least
would have been ignorant going into it
you know cut off whatever you think okay
look if there's anyone i'm gonna do this
with i'm glad it's matt
all right
there we go macy was getting a good
knife oh
you okay dude you can't even talk that's
fine
are you gonna eat all of um
sure
you're gonna eat all of that i'll take
that yeah
well let me just get into a bite that
i'm
casey i feel like you got you you lost a
lot of your crust yeah i didn't get as
much quest because you got the edge so
nervous man are you nervous at all i'll
have a piece but i want you guys to know
that like i can barely eat hot cheetos
so like i'll probably be dying and uh
but i'm down i'm down for a little piece
yeah look how right alex look man are we
comparing
or are we eating oh oh look at me i got
my cake i got mine you know what if
you're like like josh said if i'm gonna
do something i'm glad it's with matt
there we go
i'm nervous with you guys i don't know
what to expect i've never had this
chicken before okay so
all right cheers too
cheers i've got a tap come on cheers
i can feel it in my nostrils i did not
even have water jack
you didn't water immediately oh you're
comparing my bite to your bite
or are you
not because if i remember it correctly
maisie that's why i go first but i got
all breading i didn't even get any nice
little relief in there
you better hand me that water
it's hot dude
yeah
it's it's hot but it hasn't really hit
me yet it's gonna get worse i feel like
it's that hey it's sad
[Music]
are you okay man i'm sorry i didn't mean
to bring you i did mean to bring you
into this right
when you're
causing pain
oh
i mean graham you're laughing worse i
know that much tim's laughing maniacally
in the corner over there like shaking
because he's laughing too hard
when you're acting
you think this is
bad your eyes are softer
yeah it's
[Laughter]
yeah
the water tastes sweet
alex why did you agree to do this
i feel so powdery
yeah refill me yeah thank you thank you
i need water
anyone else oh thank you sorry
when there's water on my tongue it
doesn't burn
maybe like an ice cube or something of
ice cubes maybe i don't know
oh my god if i post this it's uh
my stomach houston
yeah
it makes the most hottest damn chicken
yeah that's hot
oh
my stomach hurts man yeah my mind too my
esophagus is burning
my tummy still on fire
this is fun how bad does this be matt
let's see how it went then oh it wasn't
that bad what
i mean i'm
i've i've done some spicy challenges now
my lips are burning like i i don't know
this that yeah i use uh i think it was a
quantity thing if i ate ten of these
yeah it'd be
or even like five or even two like
it's hot spicy challenges this is why i
avoided them for so long because you
feel like it's destroying your body like
when i was like i'm like i can't
but
i i would never do like crazy crazy
crazy spicy stuff but uh
i could see why they make you sign a
waiver yeah right yeah because like
especially what if you get it in your
eyes too like i'm sure like that's even
worse for you yeah but your eyes are so
red matt
at first i thought it was just maybe
because i'm done before and stuff but i
think you guys probably actually got
some a worse cut i think you got more
spices
just by the reaction
i was kind of curious
a little bit
i just like
sneezed some up and now my nostrils are
burning i might be against ten of these
things i gotta figure out my opponent
that's good man so usually we turn it
back to you and we said do you have any
questions for us
um
by the way i noticed
you got a mighty fine prius out there
a man of culture i see everything's got
200 000 miles on it really we're due for
a new car yeah we're waiting to move out
to finally get a new car and stuff but
uh what year is it because i used to
have a 2006.
i think it's a 2006 toyota prius i don't
remember the year
i honestly don't
looks like a six day to an eight it's so
it's old it's been around for a minute
so
yeah no i mean um
yeah i mean we're looking to make the
upgrade to tesla like everybody else is
doing it seems like the way to go and i
guess
you know seven dollar gas is coming yeah
so what's been your decision to drive a
car that's almost 20 years old toyota
prius 200 000 miles on it
um
i would i was expecting because
sometimes you go out there and you see
like you know
big youtubers you're like oh wow that's
a nice car sure sure yeah i mean i've um
i've never like all my friends and stuff
were always more into cars than i was i
was never a huge huge cards person for
the most part
but i mean
uh i guess in principle for me it's like
to mean the transportation yeah get you
from one place to other if anything the
more
the more it costs the more you got to
worry about a ding or
you know hitting a curb or something
oh my gosh
oh my god
[Music]
[Laughter]
so
you don't have a passion for cars so you
just figure why not have a cheap one
yeah for i mean for the most part i mean
i think um
in general i've uh
i
i'm not big on like uh materialistic
stuff i mean like i i i definitely
appreciate you know like owning like
having nice things going out for a nice
meal yeah buying some pokemon packs for
yourself every once in a while yeah you
know but yeah like there's like special
like experiences attached with that
they're having a dinner out opening some
packs with some friends or something or
even just like a business expense
spending something on some content but
uh
yeah i mean i
that car needs to be upgraded i'm not
going to sit here and deny that you know
we need to upgrade the car for sure
we're going to
but um yeah it's just it's the lack of
urgency i think for the most part yeah
the biggest upgrade i made recently is
get like an espresso or something yeah
that's a good purchase it's a good it's
it it spoils you and stuff but uh i
worry that i'm gonna get have a hard
time with pot coffee but yeah coffee
coffee you don't have an expensive taste
you wouldn't say
[Music]
i don't think so but i would like to
oh
what would you buy like like refined
taste like i want to figure out like
sushi i want to figure out good steak
whiskey like pokeballs like being able
to distinguish a good pokeball from a
not so good pokeball and be able to like
make those cogs turn and stuff yeah from
that standpoint just you know better to
appreciate food on
a higher level i mean i do already but
just you know it's just
it's something that interests me for the
most part but uh i'm flexible i think is
the best way to say it okay
cool and you're building a house right
now though right or you just finished um
it's been a nightmare yeah because
the dream was to get you know a nice
house with a good foundation and a good
like area with you know
everything and um renovate it to what we
need you know get a nice new kitchen in
there because i i assume that no matter
what house unless
one just lined the stars aligned that i
would need to rebuild the kitchen
anyways which is pretty expensive you
know just proper setup
and um
sorry
it's a little hiccup um
yes it's been a nightmare i got i
purchased the house back in
and permits
nightmare it was i got it at the right
time
i purchased it for kind of like numbers
and stuff i purchased for a little under
half a mil and now it's like estimated
like 800 the navy the neighbor neighbor
purchased theirs for like the same price
just sold it for 1.2 yeah and um so we
got in at the right time renovations are
way more expensive than i was hoping to
be but i i think
once once the dust has settled it's
going to be an awesome thing
and then vegas is cool that's the one
question i had we i briefly talked about
it but you know we moved out to vegas
roughly at the same time and yeah just
if you had any thoughts living here
i miss i gotta say i miss the weather
sure uh the weather now is kind of
comparable i do miss like that that
feeling of the breezy ocean sure and i
miss some of the the culture
i i found that like la had a very
creative artsy
very like free thinking sort of vibe to
it that i really liked like that venice
vibe
and vegas is a little bit more i don't i
don't want to say like family but a
little bit more you know
i don't know what's the worst i don't
know the word the opposite thing that
people would normally think but it's
kind of more like corporate and
structured and you know i i appreciate
that too but i liked the artsyness of of
los angeles and that like
entrepreneurial vibe that's not as much
here it's getting there though i think
more people are bringing that to parts
of vegas but uh it's the one part i do
miss but otherwise i'd like it here a
lot
yeah i mean pretty much the same thing i
mean
it's been cool it's been a good
experience and stuff and i'm still
surprised that they're expanding the
strip as fast as they got that globe
going up over there you know what i have
to say that everyone in vegas is very
friendly
way friendlier than i expected that's
something that my girlfriend noticed too
she's like everybody here seems nicer
and the way i articulated that was like
or not articulating them
imagine this is like uh
these were always living in san jose
everybody was just spending all day just
paying the bills and like and just that
that was that you're this you know work
as part of silicon valley and stuff and
it feels more free here yeah feels a lot
more free more liberating and
you know having a backyard is nice and
all that yeah
uh yeah
in la at least um like we didn't really
know our neighbors and it was one of
those things just like maybe this is me
but i'd like kind of keep my distance
from the neighbors you don't wanna
you know you might ever see each other
you kind of a little nod or whatever but
that's about it it's kind of awkward if
you see each other at the same time but
here i've i've
both gone out of my way to meet the
neighbors or they've introduced
themselves before for like walking down
the street it's uh very welcoming here
sure
so let's see any other questions how
much how much do you save
let's let's get into let's get into some
of that
um tell us about your philosophies of
saving that's
i guess there's two ways to answer that
in some way
um
i think by default a lot of times i save
up a lot because
my cost of production is so
minuscule you know i gotta i go i go to
mcdonald's and go to the menu yeah and
then i post the video and it gets a
million views with a sponsor or
something on it
so generally saving hasn't been
something that i've been too calculated
about you know generally it's kind of
been um
i've always had this philosophy though
that you get what you put in like back
when i started competitive eating
nathan's hot dogs are like
six dollars for a five pack bar s is
like
a dollar for a six pack you know yeah
and but i needed to get ready for those
hot dogs so i've always had this
mentality of like you know you just you
reinvest you reinvest and if you you're
smart about it and you put the work
behind it then
uh you'll get your money back at some
point in time
and just makes you work that much harder
because you've got more kind of yeah on
the line stuff and
um but saving wise um i try not to save
too much um
like from a standpoint of like getting
it invested in somewhere like
uh my first major investments um still
work you know slowly growing the
portfolios uh real estate
just getting condominiums in the same
building that under good property
manager and they've been it's been good
for me you're in vegas
honolulu oh wow yeah honolulu i figured
there's multiple reasons for it
but two of the reasons that i thought
are kind of interesting is
well one i love it there you know it's
great so if it didn't work out then i
got a condom on honolulu yeah um
uh but
you know it's a vacation marked it
it's international too so it's it's
potentially less volatile compared to
you know it's you know
and you know hope you know people come
to hawaii and
and uh
yeah it just it was a good it was and we
we visit there a lot too because that's
where our parents met in honolulu so
i knew the space i knew the area and
everything and
it worked out so i've been
doing some real estate investments
airbnb
no through a a professional um
property management company
got it and they rent short term or what
are the or is it like for a year it's
it's it's not crazy long term um
one of the benefits of their company is
they actually outside of uh vacation
travel they also have uh they work with
the government
pearl harbor people so people are going
in and out of there so it's been pretty
regular it's sometimes it's that
sometimes vacation but it's been
fortunately very steady from that
respect to things so
so yeah i mean that's that's been good
um
i was also gonna that was a question i
was gonna ask you how much like has has
your real estate situation changed
significantly since you know taking more
of the you know
the content yeah side of things yeah
i've stopped investing in real estate
stopped investing interesting yeah it's
it's just the uh the the time commitment
right now is i can't handle it so uh
like i got
a vacancy and a repair going on the
repair is something like
i've just i've left calls unanswered
because i just i got it i gotta focus on
the planning so it's like that falls to
the side
it's going to affect the renovation uh
and then the other the other one i got a
property manager on but because i'm not
like on-site i'm really relying on this
guy for everything and i'm just like
whatever it is i don't care don't even
don't even call to do it i trust you
yeah um
so i want to get back into it this year
but i want to do it uh smarter with like
a bigger building
that uh could be completely managed
where i could be the one just you know
being the one to pick the deal but have
someone else take care of all the
details that's the only way it's going
to work yeah yeah that i mean that was
my thought because i didn't want to be
in the business of like
like you know you did the duplex thing
and everything like um
not that it's a bad decision it just
depends on your lifestyle
where you are at that point so i didn't
and i mean
i chose honolulu too like
somebody like you know so
i i had to do something that was hands
off and stuff so that was that thought
um
from there a couple years ago i tried
the market you know just just haven't
seen tried the market what happened just
jumping in just it was
i did all right you know it was it was
um when the you know corona hit and
everything so the market was pretty low
so i felt like there was an
opportunistic time to jump in and stuff
and it was hard to not were you
investing prior to then or no you just
bought holding cash
yeah really i just jumped in yeah i just
i don't know
yeah
why were you holding cash before then
how long no why oh why yeah well same
problem it's just like
i mean it's a
problem you know but um
my cost of
doing operations is not high and you
know you're making the money and stuff
so it just accumulates and i had
previously put them in like the real
estate and stuff um didn't want to go
too heavy into that without exploring
other options so since then i've i've
worked with financial advisors now and
they're managing the money and stuff but
for the little period of time i had some
fun
where are you invested now do you know
which funds you're invested in uh there
i mean
i trust the guys i'm working with and i
see some of the things that they send
over and they're all over the place can
i can i do could you have a statement or
something we did this before who was it
that we saw a statement the only fans
girl oh yes stella showed us the
statement and we're like you're
overpaying on this one who was it i
forget their their fees were fee-wise
yeah they had a fee and then they
invested in a fund with a fee as well or
something like that yeah on top of the
high fee for the name for that i
remember hearing something about yes it
was stella yeah but it was through i
think it was through like a friend or
like it was a friend's aunt or someone
like that sure but she was putting her
in like these very very very safe like
overly safe funds but charging i think
it was like a half percent
fee a year that was 100 allocation to
one fund it wasn't like the the
financial advisor diversified and picked
stocks it was just like everything into
one fund yeah sure was like at that
point why would you need to finance yeah
i was gonna say just like no-brainer
decisions stuff yeah yeah it was all in
one fund but the but but they were
charging five percent a year just for
that one fund
um
which but that fund could also be very
easily replicated for free
um
instead of going with you know what
whatever yeah it was like somebody
charged you yeah i mean the money was
nasty reference you may not be 100
correct but it was basically a high fee
yeah sure if you have a statement i
could take a look at it and not know
that i i honestly i don't know bring a
statement for it and stuff i mean i know
i i made sure to put a decent amount in
so that you know that the fee was lower
and stuff just to get that perk um it
seems like they've been busy you know i
see i kept some of the things that
they've invested in and stuff um
something like why would you do that you
know
you know it's it's uh
it's been interesting to just just be
part of the market just a little bit and
stuff um
do you have any questions for us
no i just uh how you doing i guess
there's a question
i'm good honestly if the heat has worn
off my stomach hurts a little bit more
yeah it's starting to get here a little
bit for me too but overall man i'm just
so happy that you're here this been so
this is a look at this table man i feel
proud please look at that table easton
yeah i'm just happy oh man well thank
you so much i really appreciate this
this has been uh
actually i believe this is now the
longest episode we have ever done um
but not only that's the most delicious
we got amazing food we'll link to your
information down below in the
description with the pokeballs which
were fantastic and
houston i can't believe you were able to
come through in 40 minutes with one of
everything from your restaurant that was
a surprise also a huge shout out to
houston's hot chicken if you guys are in
las vegas check it out just just look on
the map houston's hot chicken go in and
then say that graham sent you and i'm
sure they're going to be very confused
but be like no no just insist graham
sent me
so yeah houston's hot chicken stoney
bowl check out stoney bowls soon
delivery apps everywhere and i like it a
lot of delicious sesame oil was the best
and with whatever whatever that is the
shrimp shrimp is yeah that's that's a
sleeper it wouldn't be the type of thing
i would normally order like a poke or a
rice bowl place but that's get that the
shrimp that that was my favorite one
yeah very good stuff yeah thank you so
much for coming yeah one more question
yeah go for it why isn't this called the
coffee table you're out of the room and
we're talking about it
we never have to decide why it's called
the coffee table that's a genius name
yeah actually because for those who
don't see it there's coffee in this it's
so cool i love craft work like this i
love wood with the red it's it's
the bottom
thank you guys so much for watching
we'll link to your information down
below make sure to subscribe make sure
to also get your free stock down below
it's worth up to a thousand dollars when
you use the good grammar center for
public
thank you
thank you thank you macy
until next time
thanks matt that was awesome yeah no
thank you yeah that was fun